[Music]
a dog was abandoned for being gay
adopted by a gay couple
okay nice i think my dog's gay you think
which one backstage i ain't gay
well we'll show the photo just for
emotional context that's why everybody
that's a gay dog
you definitely get that vibe
how do you tell the gay people west
hollywood written all over his face how
fabulous man what a fabulous dog does it
say anywhere in there how they found out
the doggy was gay
what do you think i think i know yeah i
remember every time we go to the dog
park
he couldn't resist [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of all the boy dogs
that's like my dog dude i'll never
forget my grandfather who was you know a
[ __ ] veteran from multiple wars
he had this dog named rusty and he loved
his dog rusty
and he took he took his dog rusty to my
uncle mark's ranch one time and then we
all watched my grandpa watching his dog
rusty getting pounded in the ass by my
uncle's dog and my grandpa looked like
he lost his best friend
he's just watching his little boy
getting [ __ ] railed
he's just standing there watching it
like
like he's he's like i can't believe this
[ __ ] he's like this is what my uncle did
to me
all the wars that's the most
traumatizing thing i can't believe this
[ __ ] yeah we thought that the dog was
gonna bite back or [ __ ] him back or
something or at least be the [ __ ] but
it said his [ __ ] his dog was the [ __ ]
for sure so this dog uh named his fesco
was handed back to the stanley county
animal protective services because uh
which is a shelter so your dog's uh you
gave me a gay dog yeah the owner thought
that the dog was gay and didn't want him
anymore you left him in the shelter's
care you gave me a defective dog
that's probably how they said it too i
didn't know he was gay
oh you didn't know he's gay he doesn't
smell my ass all the time yeah he smells
my dick all the time probably trying to
suck my dick this is what he's trying to
do
every time my friends come over he just
wants to suck their dicks and [ __ ] their
leg
so fesco's previous owners discovered
him sexually dominating another male dog
dominating causing them to believe he
was gay
however
obviously everybody who [ __ ] knows
anything about dogs knows that this [ __ ]
just happens
and it's a lot it's usually due to or i
guess scientifically speaking vets say
that it's due to a high level of
testosterone and you know obviously the
dog does want to breed even though it
doesn't necessarily mean that humping
another male dog is the way to do it so
it's like the equivalent of like us just
making engaging each other yeah yeah but
i mean there's times when we start like
you know pretending that
i mean
we still have sex
we stimulate sex a lot
off-camera
[Laughter]
i mean how many pictures are there of
chicks like mounting each other
[Laughter]
go to the dog park it's [ __ ]
pansexual as [ __ ] everyone's humping
each other you got girl doggies humping
[ __ ] all everybody it's a big origin
you know the best part unlike us there's
no judgment of the dog that's true
that's right every dog is like it's all
love love is love they're so [ __ ]
binary dude yeah non-binary oh they're
non-binary yeah
they're so fine they don't give a [ __ ]
about gender roles dude if the dude so
the dog got adopted by a gay couple yeah
what if the dog goes back to the shelter
he's like these guys are gay
[Laughter]
socks like scooby doo
he's like yo what the [ __ ]
i just haven't touched
i mean
in terms of
in terms of a certain asserting
dominance over other dogs in multi-dog
context the behavior could also be
explained by dogs having a pecking order
and knowing where their pecking order is
so i could imagine that in their you
know more limited capacity of like like
uh interaction with other beings yeah
yeah it's kind of like oh i go to a dog
park i need to know where i stand i'm
either going to hump or get humped and
like i'm a humper yeah you know okay
well like a her on saturdays but on
tuesdays when we come here parks and
just pumper over there's here you know
what i mean so it's like they probably
just do that in order to discover that
like social order but it's not
necessarily
good or maybe it is i don't know i'm no
vet you know or maybe they're just
comparing styles
yeah they're comparing those like
past word around this is how i do it
pass the word around
like let them know you you know any girl
dogs
[Laughter]
talk about your boyfriend fesco was here
he was just trying to give him a massage
you know you're trying to give him a
sample yeah this is a [ __ ] dog
shiatsu dog shiatsu you know when i when
i uh finally got my second cat uh
morpheus uh that's when i started seeing
so much more of like you know inner two
cats behaving with each other there's so
much butt smelling right you know we see
this with dogs and stuff like that too
but i had to i had to like google i was
like what really is going on was it what
was it when a cat is like sniffing
another cat's ass always and then i
learned that when cat they have so many
senses and abilities you know that we
don't have that when they smell another
animal's butthole they can it's like
both a greeting and uh how have you been
doing how's your health like oh you can
smell your [ __ ] as well right so it's
like i could tell if you're a healthy
being right now or there's something
wrong with you so i should stay away so
they have like all that intuition yeah
wow a single sniff imagine what they're
doing when they're humping a leg
imagine if that's how we checked in with
each other like yo how you been dog
let me tell you good drop your drone
he's just like
joe's not doing well man you smell his
ass
struggling
to get a whiff oh [ __ ] did you lose
somebody in your family
you know when you start eating all
healthy and [ __ ] you start eating super
healthy your [ __ ] smells [ __ ] dank it
smells yeah dank is for sure [ __ ]
crazy right but you start eating like
mcdonald's and stuff all the ways
processed food and there's like no smell
you're like chilling you're taking the
biggest shits but it doesn't smell bad
do you guys remember the last emperor
that oh yeah that movie do you remember
that scene when he [ __ ] shits in that
[ __ ] little robin bowl yeah yeah and
then he's they [ __ ] analyze it they
like worship it and stuff dude make sure
he's healthy making sure he's healthy
right now i have to watch this movie now
that's the best sell i've ever heard for
a [ __ ] movie in my life
he shits in a bowl and everyone starts
worshiping it it's pretty it's but it's
realistic it's really funny because
that's how they checked for diseases or
worms and all those stuff yeah like if
you got like a black stool you're kind
of like oh [ __ ] am i bleeding on the
inside you know what i mean so so when
somebody when somebody farts and like
really really smelly i'm like oh
somebody's healthy around here
you know really you think somebody would
smelly today
wait so bart has like the worst farts
ever bart the thing about bart though he
he consumes so much protein so it just
smells like eggs and that's what
happened
it smells like sulfur yeah like exactly
like that's how it's supposed to smell
from eating too many eggs well that's
just that's just a lot that's a high
protein diet you know i mean like when
you're pounding protein like that yeah
now that like i've been eating a lot
healthier and stuff i've been noticing
like my farts
everything is just like [ __ ] hey when
i feel like i'm eating healthy my farts
don't and poops don't really smell so
are you really healthy
aren't you yes okay
that was very guilty yeah yeah
it shouldn't smell like rotting [ __ ]
flesh though dude yeah yeah those things
are staying in your intestines for life
something's up well no it's getting
ripped it's getting rid of all of it
because you're eating healthy it's
getting ripped
exhaust
gases but eventually if you're healthy
all the time it gets rid of it and then
it doesn't smell like anything i always
heard that if you fart a lot that means
you're healthy because then your body's
doing it's not
healthy yesterday though doing its
natural process of getting out all the
toxins does inhaling farts make you less
healthy it makes you actually more
healthy or just almost like fart out
it's harder because you have data on
everybody
[Laughter]
you know where everyone's at
but here's one of my farts if you want
to know about me so dogs [ __ ] each other
because they have too much testosterone
they're just trying to blossom steam is
that the game i don't know about [ __ ]
each other because i think
i think the one that is doing the
[ __ ] has testosterone for sure
because you know even like a neutered
dog will still like thrust and stuff
there's still testosterone there's still
an
animal instinct but it but it's like a
dominance thing i think right they're
trying to show like oh i'm bigger better
stronger than you because i walked in on
my [ __ ] cats and
one of my cats was on top of the other
cat and he was like kneading he's like
he's walking on him and then he was
humping the air over his body it was
weird to say sometimes they miss he's
like it's a massage mouth
when you watch turtles have sex yes
exactly
yeah
they're both like neutered and [ __ ] i
don't know you never heard turtles have
sex no they make the [ __ ] funniest
sounds ah yeah yeah you got to see it
actually this is good [ __ ] who has not
seen a turtle have sex
i have i've seen the turtle exhale and
it's kind of cute yeah it's like i've
seen that tortoise sex is hilarious dude
it's great here we go this one has uh
3.1 million views why not just listen
oh he's about to get it out
[ __ ] let's uh let's get let's get out
here and get a little quicker he's like
whoa
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
just get on with it it's a good sound
right it's great
for her
he's struggling right now oh
[ __ ]
okay
look at this crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
just out of nowhere at the end just
cowabunga
my friend had two tortoises that were
like that big and they were gay
would they [ __ ] each other like they
were [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're gay gay tortoises it would have
been great if if they panned down and he
pulls out and just blows all over the
show
he's like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
only eight and a half minutes
[Music]